- Okay, so, here we are.
This is Eating Your Feed,
a show where our friend, Adam, challenges us
to recreate some of the most viral foods from the internet.
Today, we also have our friend Annie.
- Behind the camera.
We've actually done this before.
- [Niki] We have, and it has been a lot of fun.
- So, today on Eating Your Feed
^we're gonna be making this cheeseburger,
^but the cheese is a sauce that gets dunked on top.
- Liquid cheese.
^- As always, we have Rie,
^(cheering)
^who's a Tasty producer, chef extraordinaire.
- Andrew and I are not experts, but we try very hard.
^So, this is called the Cheesebomb
^at a restaurant in London called Maxwell's.
- It's kind of getting close to one of my other fantasies,
^savory cereal.
- What?
- A cheesy porridge that has little hamburgers
floating in it.
- Oh, what?
- I wouldn't do this.
(laughing)
- Well, we're doin' it today.
- Okay.
What is your plan for making this melty cheese?
- I don't know, I was gonna look it up.
I don't know how to make melty cheese.
- Something called a roux?
- Yeah, like bechamel.
^- Oh, bechamel.
- Really?
Alright, let's get ingredients.
Thanks, Rie.
Butter, milk, flour, homey, comforting, blah, blah, blah,
- Mature cheddar cheese.
Nice.
- That's the kind of cheese we'll get.
^Adam just said, "Isn't a bechamel plus cheese a mornay?"
- Do you have a preference
on what kind of burger you'd like to make?
I prefer carm...
- Adam says he wants a thick patty style.
- Thick patty style's my specialty.
I also like putting avocado on things.
- No.
Fine, get avocado.
I don't care, we're in California, whatever.
- Yeah, we can do this.
- Let's go get this cheese.
(slapping)
- [Niki] It's a little treat for later.
Very nice, brioche.
- It's $12 a pound.
That's fantastic.
(saxophone music)
- Burger.
^- So, here are all out grocesses.
Beef, butter, yellow cheddar cheese, white cheddar cheese,
and backup cheese that Adam made us get.
- Backup cheese.
- Oranges 'cause...
- They're delicious and in season.
- It's exceedingly regular.
Avogadro, brioche buns.
- Buns.
- Onions
because we're gonna caramelize some onions for our burger,
thick cut bacon.
Look at how thick that is.
- So thick.
- Some fries, and then tomatoes and some lettuce
to top our burger with.
I think we're gonna make the cheese sauce first.
- How does this work?
Wow, what are you doing?
- I don't know.
I just have to keep pressing it until something happens.
This is a crumbly cheddar.
- You're a crumbly cheddar.
We're melting butter.
Stop eating it all!
- Saucepan, oooo!
- Adam recommended we use more milk,
but I forgot and now
we don't have enough time.
- Well, Adam's not making the
(bleep) roux so we're gonna go with this milk.
Oh, that looks good!
- That looks good.
- Cheese sauce.
When we add cheese to this bechamel, that's amore.
'Cause it's amore sauce, you guys.
I don't hear any laughter.
- It's a mornay.
- Oh!
- So, I'm just gonna keep stirring this until it gets thick,
and then we'll add the cheese.
(clearing throat)
- Stir it until it's thick.
- That's what I just said.
- Adding the cheese is so much fun,
I'm having a hard time stopping.
(slurping)
- I think we definitely got the right texture.
^- Texture.
- [Niki] Oh, I should've made you cut these, I'm gonna cry.
- Let's add the onions before the butter burns.
- [Niki] Let's make burger patties.
- So vibrant!
You think doctors ever are like...
In E.R. they're like...
- Congratulations, doctor.
Thank you, doctor.
No, because that would make them not sterile.
Sometimes when I cook onions at home, like a lot of them,
my cat, walking in the kitchen will be like...
(laughing)
- I actually need to change this glove
'cause I touched the floor.
- You touched the floor?
Fatty patty.
- Your burgers are gargantuan.
These are Niki's, those are mine.
(tapping)
I like to make a lot of sounds when I cook.
- Do you need to take a minute?
- No, I'm doing great.
Where's my coffee?
- We've got bacon and we've got fries.
Don't... (groans)
Why do you put everything in your mouth?
- I am going to bake my bacon.
Look how thick that is.
Is the oven preheated?
Did you put...
- I threw my fries in already.
- Your fries?
- The fries.
- I'm gonna go put my bacon in the oven.
- He's so salty today.
Do you think these onions are almost done?
- I think that they can keep going.
I like them tacky.
Juicy tomato.
What beautiful produce to drown in cheese.
- These look very crisp.
- The bacon has become bacon.
- Got a crisp, but it's still jiggly.
Good job.
(laughing)
Oh, it smells good!
- We can probably toast our bun in the same thing, actually.
- [Niki] Yeah, get some mayo on there.
Nice, that's a nice looking burger.
- Fan that away from the fire alarm, please.
Why don't I just move this?
- Careful!
- Yeah, unplug...
- The lettuce is on the bottom,
and I'm gonna put the avocado underneath that.
Okay, onions.
- Alright, I'm comin' in with a bacon strip.
Yeah, let's top her off.
You ready to jar up our cheese sauce?
- Yes, yeah!
I mean, our burger looks really good.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- [Niki] I would be really excited to eat that regardless.
- Yeah, even if it didn't have
a giant jug of cheese on the side.
- So, we brought Rie back.
Rie, look at what we did!
Look!
- So pretty!
^It just look like the video.
^- Doesn't it?
- Yeah, good job.
- This is getting not so warm anymore.
We ready?
- Just pour it slowly and don't use all the cheese.
- Okay, here we go.
- [Andrew] Oh, yes!
- [All] Whoa!
- It's so satisfying.
Yes!
Whoa.
Go, go!
(groaning)
Oh, he's still eating it.
It must be good.
- It must be good.
- You want a bite?
- I guess.
Sloppy seconds, here we go.
(laughing)
That's a great burger.
(screaming)
(slapping)
Nailed it.
(groaning)
I wonder what else we can cheese.
- I think we should make some more
and then cheese some other stuff.
- Alright, let's do it.
- No lumps, no lumps, no lumps.
Oh!
- We have a smorgasbord to cover with cheese.
We have three more burgers, we have a slice of lasagna,
meatballs, chicken wings, and Brussels sprouts.
- [Andrew] For our vegetarian friends.
- On our dessert plate, we have some burnt marshmallows,
pizza, chocolate bunny, ice cream, and macaron.
We invited some of our friends.
Ready?
- Yeah.
- Okay, guys, come on in.
Alright, ready?
- On top of the bun?
- [Blonde Woman] That seems a little ridiculous.
(all talking)
- [Andrew] How are we gonna eat this?
- What?
- You can no longer eat the burger!
- [All] Whoa!
- [Andrew] We're gonna do some more experiments.
- [Niki] You want some lasagna?
- [Man] I love lasagna.
- Are you putting cheese on this ice cream?
- Yeah.
- We're about to!
(all yelling)
- This is gonna be actual garbage.
Don't do it.
- That's not good.
- That's a win.
- That's a winner!
- Okay, so today we made a delicious liquid cheese sauce.
It's good on some things.
- Oh, no, that's so bad.
- Better on others, terrible on some.
^- [Niki] I think we nailed this cheese sauce.
^- [Andrew] I think we got pretty close
^to the restaurant's rendition of the burger
^covered with cheese.
- I think so.
- [Blonde Woman] The fountain of fondue.
- No, I don't wanna do this, I don't wanna...
- [All] Do it, do it, do it, do it.
- Chug, chug!
- I'm not doing that.
I think we finally answered the question today
is there a such thing as too much cheese.
- [Niki] Yeah.
- [Andrew] Oh, yes!